et on revient aux sports et la journée a
été riche en événements puisque ce soir
l'équipe de france de handball est
devenue championne du monde un titre de
plus pour une équipe d'experts comme on
les appelle qui était déjà je vous le
rappelle championne olympique en titre
avant de les retrouver une finale que
nous raconte aron dans heat
ils sont champions du monde
cinq mois après leur titre olympique les
français remporte le mondial croate
fantastic karabatic qui gagnent sur la
terre de ses ancêtres dans la reine de
zagreb devant 15 mille supporters la
france défie la croatie chez elle les
deux meilleures équipes de la planète
ont rendez vous si en première période
les français réalisent des prouesses
techniques
ce match reste avant tout un combat
ultra défensif la france est prise dans
la tenaille adverse nous annonce pour la
croatie à la mi temps mais les champions
olympiques ont de la ressource
ils recollent au score et dépasse même
les croates grâce à leur gardien thierry
omeyer
sur le terrain les esprits s'échauffent
balitsch la star croate s'en prend à
karabatic
le français lui répond en marquant un
but décisif qui donne deux buts d'avancé
à la france
à vingt minutes de la fin les croates ne
reviendront plus les français file vers
un troisième sacre mondial
score final 24 à 19 au sommet de
l'olympe à pékin l'année dernière sur le
toit du monde à zagreb aujourd'hui multi
très que les footballeurs français
les experts comme on les surnomme vient
d'écrire une page sublime de l'histoire
du sport tricolore
et à les entendre on a bien l'impression
qu'ils ne sont pas prêtes cela c'est de
chanter la marseillaise
et on